Dany: Russia is now in Syria. Vladimir Putin has taken the Crimea.
We seem to have forgotten about it as a nation
already. They're in Donetsk, they're in Luhansk.
There's some suspicion they may even go into
some of our NATO-allied countries.
Are we handling Putin correctly?
Cheney: I don't think so. I think Putin believes
he's got a window here that runs to the end
of the Obama Administration.
We've seen him move on to Crimea as you pointed
out, in the Ukraine, now he's in Syria.
It's as though he is trying to recreate elements
of the old Soviet Empire that came apart back
in '90 and '91.
I think he also has aspirations on the Baltics.
I think he'd like nothing better than to be
able to put pressure on the Baltics.
Not so much directly by military action, but
they all get all of their energy supplies,
their gas all comes from Russia. They were
all part of Russia at one time.
The Russians appear to be spending money on
trying to influence the internal politics
of the Baltics.
So if he could stir up enough trouble, I could
see him trying to put pressure on the Baltics
that they either have to do what he wants
them to do, probably withdraw from NATO, or
some additional pressures will be brought
to bear on the Baltics.
I think that's his real objective. Now will
he pull it off? I don't know and I question
at this point how determined NATO would in
fact be without strong U.S. leadership.
We provide 75% of the funding for NATO and
the defense budgets here in the U.S. have
been cut dramatically. That's provided a rationale
for the Europeans to afford and cut their
defense budgets as well. So it's worrisome.